hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast one test path Oh genome a
target hybridization based
next-generation sequencing assay to
tackle undiagnosed infections it is
presented by Mohammed Khedira PhD the
president and chief scientific officer
at fusion genomics I am Judy O'Rourke of
laberd's and I will be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring this educational web seminar
presented by laven roots lab roots is
the leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before I
begin I'd like to remind everyone this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box that
appears on the screen our speaker will
respond to your questions via email if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits please
join me in welcoming dr. Kadir I will
now turn the presentation over to him
hello everybody and welcome first of all
I would like to begin with thanking the
organizers or according me this
opportunity and to all the viewers and
every other as well welcome so we are
here to talk about massively multiplex
Diagnostics for infectious diseases the
question is is that we would be want to
impress addresses what do we mean by
massively multiplex and why do
massively multiplayer at gnostics to
begin with so before we go any further
it just an affront conflict conflict of
interest I am the chief scientific
officer at fusion as mentioned us do
have financial holdings in the company
also would like to mention that the
assay and the data which I am sharing
with you today most of is this
unpublished and also the assay at this
moment is for research use only and thus
it is not for clinical or diagnostic
purposes for any human or animal testing
and if I am talking about other
companies and their products or anything
they are only for educational purposes
on an ass's without warranty basis so
without further ado let's begin unless
not the answer or ask the question why
do we need massively multiplex
Diagnostics as you can see on your
screen the problem in infectious
diseases and and the esteem audience
will also be aware of it that many of
the hospitalized patients so we are
restricting our discussion from here
onwards to patients who are hospitalized
and and and during their stay in the
hospitals many patients remain
undiagnosed for example you have the
examples ranging from pneumonia to
diarrhea to manage itis and substance
even was not on the screen an area where
the current molecular diagnostics have
made a huge leap which is the PCR based
panels for upper respiratory syndromes
I was surgery surprised you will learn
that but many of you may already be
aware that during peak flu season for
example where you have patients in the
ER who are clearly in distress
because of upper respiratory or
respiratory involvement and yet when you
run them onto these PC O'Connell's the
acid still comes out as negatives so and
I'm sure all of you are already aware of
the cases in sepsis in GI so this is the
problem oh the other thing about this
problem is it is a medical problem and
and the same time it also creates a
massive burden on the health care system
and and that burden can be viewed as for
example by conservative estimates by
others published data and such the cost
of hospice of a patient remaining
undiagnosed because of in idiopathic or
again undiagnosed infections throughout
this stay in a hospital or during their
stay in the hospital the yearly cost in
the United States alone as approximately
27 billion dollars now it is a big cost
and the breakups are also presented for
some of the things on the side if this
was only the thing we'll say okay it's a
one thing that this is a direct cost but
what is also very medically also
interesting about this that these
patients also all part of a major
contributor to them indirect casting
which results in things like
antimicrobial resistance so how do we
solve this problem well as smart people
say that in order to address a problem
one has to understand it and the way we
made it us understand it or the way we
view it we view this problem
as an iceberg problem and what you see
on your screen is a cartoon iceberg
representation of how we feel the
problem has remained and will remain
until we address the magnitude what this
thing shows is that if you look at the
tip of the iceberg it it represents your
fda-approved molecular diagnostic assays
for infectious agents according to
latest estimates the 2008 publications
as well there are about 1415 known
pathogens and the FDA approved a sacar
was only about 16 percent of them and
then underneath the surface you also
have your antimicrobial resistance which
again as I which actually adds an
additional 26 billion annually to the
economy in cost and that is just us
alone and then you have your undiagnosed
infections and then underneath those
infections
you have your pandemics you know where
we hear about a Zika outbreak in things
like this they are all part of this same
iceberg and then underneath them you
have your emerging and re-emerging
pathogens for example pathogens can be
in in your population for a long time
before the emergen become a pandemic and
underneath all of that is your zoonotic
reservoir which are the pathogens which
exists in the animal world around us in
the environment around us and then when
they jump from the the animal world into
the human world then we have major
problems so we will infectious disease
not just that patient whose remaining
undiagnosed but what is needed is to
address this iceberg this hidden nature
of the problem so we ask another
question can we address this entire
iceberg and the answer is actually
surprisingly yes and that comes from the
power of genomics especially we are in
the post genomic era
and and the way it is address or the
solution is a form of whole genome
sequencing called as whole meta genome
sequencing in which what you do is you
take any biological sample or any any
sample and you would the sequence all
the DNA or all the RNA in that sample
basically you'll have a su you can take
blood sputum nasal wash biopsies you can
take environmental samples then you
would prepare all the DNA RNA in it and
then you will put it on to what is on to
a next-generation sequencer and
obviously at the end of time you will
end up with your sequence material now
what happens with the next generation
will be at all metagenomes
equal saying is that when it gives you
your results you have everything in it
you have your normal human DNA in it you
have your normal big field DNA in it you
have your normal final DNA and then also
your pathogen DNA so it creates it gives
you all this data whereas what you are
here is your pathogen DNA and for this
on these purposes the Diagnostics in
precision medicine are using whole
matter genome sequencing it is not an
ideal solution to be used to address the
problem at large now why because it
still it has a high cost yes we
understand if a medium cost of a hospice
patient is as I can be in thousands of
dollars you can spend a couple of
thousand dollar to diagnose them but
then there are edit problems which is
that it is still difficult to use one of
the reason and I just mentioned why it
is difficult to use is because of all
the data that it will generate and then
you have to sniff through all that data
to find the pathogen in question and I
still take
non-clinical it still takes longer to
perform and which is sometimes outside
the boundaries of what is required in a
clinical setting and so at this point we
ask the question okay I mentioned that
we have an answer but then I'm also
saying we don't really have an answer
because it's not that practical so where
we where we should go from there so here
we talk about which is also a variation
in molecular biology which is which is
known as target capture in target
capture what you do is you start with
your same biological sample but then
what you want to do is enrich the things
you are looking for a PCR or PCR panels
are actually an example of target
capture because you go in and amplify on
what your specific interested in the
human eggs zones sequencing is also
example of target capture the
differences that PCR panel is based on
two PCR primers amplifying whereas probe
based hybridization you make
complimentary DNA or closely related DNA
to put into that soup if you may want to
call it and capture the DNA or RNA of
target of interest and once you have
captured it you will sequence it and the
idea is that after you have done your
target enrichment or target capture once
you see cause your sample you will end
up with what you were looking for either
it is there or it is not there in a
binary sense and it also becomes
absolute because you are sequencing
you're obtaining directly genomic
sequence or whatever you are trying to
capture Oh before I go any further I
thought it might also help the audience
and I'm pretty sure that most of you are
already aware of it so just a refresher
is that a bit of the history of target
capture the target capture or
complimentary DNA hybridization it was
first discovered by dr. Edwin Sutherland
in 1975 and dr. squadron actually went
and won a Nobel Prize for the discovery
and this was the underlying technology
for all the sudden loss and northern
loss and Western plots then the next
major iteration of the technology came
in the form of DNA microarrays a started
in around the 90s by dr. Patrick brown
and and then the third iteration came
with the human egg zone in 2009 also
we're changing these interaction
iterations is that in the time of NACA
sutton or when you're doing a certain
northern blots your target whatever you
are interrogating it actually is
immobilized on an immobilized face this
used to be a nylon nylon membrane and
such and then you will add your pro or
your complimentary or you can use a tie
to go and find it when it moved from
that into DNA microarrays what happened
is that that
nitrocellulose or a nylon membrane was
then replaced by pro with your legal
nucleotides which were then put on a
glass slide then you would add your
interrogating DNA or RNA onto it and see
if it would bind you would have a
fluorescent signal and in case of human
eggs on it went a step further where
what it is called as a liquid phase
harmonization and hence the name liquid
phase capture in which both your target
and your probe are both in a liquid what
changed over here is that what you do is
when you have your complementary DNA you
attach a stripped ammidon molecule onto
it so you can so once it
just to the thing that it wants to bind
to his target and then you can put that
to you on a magnet and that way you can
take it out of the solution so to give a
final overview of this the way colligate
capture works in the liquid phase
authorization that you have a piece of
DNA and you take that piece of DNA you
have a streptavidin on it and you know
what that piece is and you use that
piece as an enricher for whatever is in
the solution if the solution contains
what you are looking for this piece will
go and bind with that piece as shown in
the cartoon and then you can pull it out
of a solution using a magnet and this is
exactly what fusion is also doing and
what the one test path of genome is over
here I like to add that we are still a
very pre-commercial so we are a very
very much an R&D enterprise and
hopefully you will see that we'll be
sharing a lot of data with you and
hopefully I will not be trying to sell
you anything we will we want this to be
a scientific presentation any baseball
we still have to talk about the
underlying technology to to effectively
communicate to the audience so we have
invented this is what we call it or
others call it as a destructive DNA RNA
capture technology and what it allows us
to do it makes these illegal needs to
try CROs which we can direct towards all
infections and that could include virus
bacteria fungi and parasites it has been
optimized to work with all biological
sample types blood sputum stool source
of swabs and others it's a single tube
assay which means that you and your
sample curves already I need to correct
that you add you need like asses so what
biological sample you have you will then
isolate your DNA or RNA depending upon
what you are interrogating on both and
then you would add it into the tube and
once your target is enriched is put on
to the sequencer and then all the data
goes to a cloud where it is analyzed and
you are provided with or with a report
and the most intriguing thing about it
that when technology will be
commercially introduced it will have
approximately a 24-hour turnaround time
which means that from DNA or RNA to your
result it will provide it within 24
hours which we want to call it as a
clinically relevant time frame one more
thing about it and then we'll move into
the data it is a kit based sample to
result assay which means it's not a
service it's a box which has everything
you need
it has a very simplified laboratory
workflow it comes with its own su suite
of analysis which is cloud based and it
is are completely secure and compliant
cloud solution which is using IBM as
this ad is back-end but more than what I
want to add over here is and the
platform of the assay has actually
already been tested in some of the most
diverse conditions of for example it is
under clinical studies at the European
Union part of their genomic effort on
their cysts on their central patients
this is the flu assay or the flu version
of the assay and it can capture and
identify every known flu and it also
provides you the complete genomic
sequence of the HM DNA regions it is the
same as a and now as I mentioned that it
is that it is
capture technology which is destructive
so more the special about that capture
technology is that the the way our
probes are designed they are not
designed against any specific species or
a reference genome they are designed
against all the known evolutionary
lineages across all known species that
we have information for so for example
what does that mean that when we have an
assay for flu it is regardless it would
work on humans it would work on birds
and it would work on swine or pigs or
for that matter any other organism
because the probe is a drive to capture
evolutionary lineage
one way of thinking of it is a way that
if you take one of our probes and you
blast it on NCBI it will not have an 800
90 80 70 percent mass to any one single
sequence but it has enough matches of
against an evolutionary lineage that it
can go and capture and bind to the
target and you are able to pull it out
and the efficacy of it is that for
example the second example on your
screen is about bird flu version of the
essay in which what you seem that cube
is actually soil and mud which is
collected around the rivers and it is in
the path of the migratory birds and the
migratory birds are dropping their bird
droppings and those dropping is in the
mud along with all the animals fecal
matter and everything else and the plant
matter in it and by using the one test
platform we are able to capture the flu
the alien flu genome from this and be
able to sequence a similarly we have a
project with
with the Sunnybrook Research Institute
in Toronto it is recently also funded by
genome Canada and an ontario genomics
Institute where what they have done is
put these air canisters around the pig
farms and using the assay you can
process the air in the pig farms and yes
we can actually capture Pig flu virus
from those air canisters and give you
the genome of the pig flu which is then
subsequently sequence so this is how
this tells you about the specificity and
the sensitivity of the platform now I
was going to some of the data which is
more human human centric here is here
are some hepatitis C patients and these
are very unusual patient's these were
among the most hard to diagnose patients
that you can ever find from a genotyping
perspective what it shows is that you
have a we should not really call them
patients these are this is the RNAs
samples which male which has T RNA
belonging to hepatitis C now if you look
at it and you focus on the greening the
thought which is labeled as a one age
what you see there is that this is an
infection this is an hepatitis C
infection which has mutated about this
16 percent for its e one gene in about
excess of 13 percent for it ms 5 B gene
from every known hepatitis C that was at
that time available so the blue thought
of the zero access is every known
genotype of hepatitis C and this one
patient or this happened either CG huge
happen either see GG know has mute
excess of 16% and the reason is very
important is that we know that our assay
has an evolutionary distance capability
of capturing and I think this is about
20 percent divergent just to give you an
example of a 20 percent average and if
you look at a gene a slightly conserved
gene I be globins or things like these a
20 percent divergent would mean is the
genetic the distance for their gene
between human and Drosophila actually is
smaller than 20 percent so it just gives
you an idea that the pros because they
were designed against the evolutionary
lineages they were able to go and
capture the hepatitis C genome which had
mutated to such an extent and all the
samples in this study were things like
these they were also even more
interesting so if you real if you look
at the table on your extreme right hand
and if you look at the sample number
seven and sample number eight we were
even able to determine that if this
sample had to hepatitis C distinct
infections present one belonging to the
genotype to be the other two three-a the
sample eight had three a and one a and
because it is it is it is an RNA
sequencing based assay the very nature
that you are capturing everything from a
solution in your sequencing game it
makes it absolute quantitation so from
that sense we were able to determine not
only the proportions of lists of these
two genotypes present in each of these
samples but we were also able to
determine the viral loads in IU per ml
the graph in the middle just gives you a
depiction that how
or during a treatment if you have a
person going through treatment you can
then track if their genotype of the
infection being targeted how it is
changing or is it being eliminated the
next slide is about the sensitivity of
the platform these are about 50/50
influenza clinical clinical samples from
the from the from the Sentinel screening
program and they were also then tested
on PCR in a clinical laboratory and by
interpreting inter by then end and they
were also tested on the one test and
what it shows you that the one test has
has a Daleks comparative sensitivity
from the pcr world to about us a CT of
53 and 54 now as you know people
especially you come from the pcr world
that a straight up PC Oct of 53 or 54
does not exist which is true but what it
means it is comparative to unmastered
pcr at the board when a sample is
sequence and about one and a half to two
million reads persists per sample moving
forward as I mentioned because we are
capturing the entire genome or regions
of the genome here is the example from
hepatitis C C where what you see on your
screen those gray things is actually the
entire genomic or the G gene was
captured and sequence for the e1 and NS
v b region we routinely had
Eve a depth of about 300 and in this in
this example this was a very uncommon 3a
genotype the next example is actually a
normal 3p so what it means is that your
strain doesn't have to be known because
you are capturing the entire genomic
region and you are sequencing that
genomic region you can also detect novel
things moving moving forward okay so so
far the data we discussed was largely
coming from single organism studies
whereas the intent of the assay is to be
massively multiplexed now you would
agree with me that yes we are designing
we are say against all along pathogens
but it's virtually impossible to test
them for like against all known pathogen
so the approach we have taken here at
fusion genomics is to test them against
both clinically challenging situations
as well as scientifically challenging
situation so for example an upper
respiratory even though we know that
there are a lot of pcr panels it's also
a technically challenging situation
especially during peak flu seasons and
especially when the PCR test gives you a
negative and then we have also tested it
in scientific challenges which patients
for example in skin ulcers where it is
very difficult either to culture those
bacteria or even culture them is to
differentiate various types and subtypes
similarly we are undertaking studies and
aim to transplant patients for various
things also in GI disorders and also and
supply to spend in gitis these are just
some of the studies we have undertaking
today I'll be sharing some of the data
from the upper upper respiratory pan
and the skin ulcers unfortunately we
cannot share the manuscript because it
is under preparation and hopefully it
should be coming out and you guys will
be able to then read it in the
manuscript and and also because a lot of
work and effort is also being put in by
our academic partners so we believe that
they should be really who should be
presenting it and not us as so much will
still talk about the data or the
take-home message from these studies
that what does it mean when you take a
genomic assay and you pitted against
whatever is out there just a little
overview that if you were to just look
at the upper respiratory how did we
design the assay so on your left hand
side are all the pathogens out of the
pathogen on which are representative of
we of the of the upper respiratory
pathogens then you can also see on the
screen all the types and subtypes which
are being targeted and we are targeting
not a single gene or a single region we
target in most cases multiple regions on
the genome and that is determined
actually in exclusivity by what is
already known about the regions one and
two how clinically important information
in that is available in those regions so
for example in case of flu we would
target and capture 100% of the hmm name
and as you can see that ranges anywhere
you know in the case of meta pneumo we
target about 98% of the F F protein and
about 88% of
nucleoprotein and similarly but again we
because the answer is a dynamic assay we
can always increase that coverage or add
a region if we think any clinical
information is available in that region
or as a new information become available
we can easily add probes targeting any
region of the genome but just to give
you an idea so what it means when you
say that your gene coverage is hundred
percent is that that if in a sample you
have flu a or flu P and you run this
assay the pros will go and bind the
entire length of the flu a and flu B so
when you will enrich and pull it out and
you will sequence it you should be able
to reconstruct the entire gene
I mean s entirety moving forward so
today I would be talking about so this
is some of the patients or small samples
again it calling me calling these
issuances incorrectly these are just
anonymized RNA and DNA and these were
already tested on the luminix our beef a
splash platform and then they were also
tested for the one test pathogen or for
the RNA and DNA and as you can see we
were in almost in in almost
hundred-percent concordant except for
this sample number 18 and i apologize
for the quality of this slide it
happened because of a conversion between
PDF and PowerPoint so my apologies and
what is interesting is that yes just
sample number 18 which was originally on
the luminix as as
we cheat as ali jinnah glee genial okay
we you can read it it was identified by
our and as a flu a and we are looking
into it but other than that we were able
to diagnose everything that was
originally diagnosed now in addition for
example what was ready what was also
interesting to us is for example if you
look at sample number five which was
negative on the RV fast but on the one
test DNA we were able to determine that
the sample had DNA from the moon here
from s munier then if you also go
towards the very end of the sheet you
also see trace what that means is
because the acid is sensitive and the
assay is capturing the genomic regions
of these viruses we were also able to in
all these sample or in most of them we
were also able to recover traces of
other pathogens now as i mentioned that
all the data is automatically analyzed
one other thing which is part of the
fusion cloud is that based upon all the
all the data which is already existing
in the cloud and our machine learning
algorithms it can actually tell you
exactly if what you are seeing is a
clinically significant infection or is
it just a trace it's just there or what
does it mean we don't know as more
sensitive asset becomes available
i'm pretty sure we would know about it
but i just wanted to mention that the
assay also have this capability now
after we saw this we became again we
already knew but it reinforced our
understanding about the about testing
being negative samples so in this study
we which was conducted with the european
union
CDC one of their Institute's it was it
is a 300 patient study but we'll just be
talking about the about B negatives and
they were performing because these are
the Sentinel Sentinel samples they were
performing about 198 different PC as
purse purse purse sample and what it
tells you that even after that about
they had about 47 cases which one which
were negative out of those 27 cases
excuse me on our end were also negative
or concordant but interestingly in 20
cases we found positivity which was
clinically significant and it happened
because of two reasons one because it's
a genomic I say we have no restriction
of how many pathogens we target and
because we were targeting every now and
upper respiratory pathogens as part of
the panel we were able to also identify
many infections which couldn't be
otherwise targeted using PCR assays or
you know they were already doing hundred
and ninety eight assay so it becomes
problem and we were able to easily
identify C or ve H MPV and PIV and also
what also happened is that we also were
able to capture additional oxygen again
the pathogens then either cannot be
tested because of the complexity or the
asses of the number of reaction the
sheer reaction that you are you would
have to do even in previously identified
infections we were able to identify any
Co infections which belong to anywhere
from from the kirino to the met animo
and to parainfluenza and adb
moving ahead what it also shows and I've
alluded to it that the assay is also
fully quantitative and it gives you our
clinical level detection of the
sensitivity and only about two million
reads what that means is that remember
we talked about the whole mataji know
sequencing that when you're doing a
whole meta genome sequencing you really
need to do about 10 million genome agree
so in their synthesis if you remember we
talked about that in a whole matter
genome you take that you when you
sequence everything but if you want to
release equals everything that you all
possible DNA RNA that would still cost
in Access of 20 30 thousand dollars but
what people do is this equals about
anywhere from 10 to 30 million here 10
10 to 30 million degrees or sampling of
the DNA from that view so when you do a
whole meta-genome meet genome sequencing
on average you need to do a minimum of
10 million genomic reads genomic reads
saplings from the two are normally about
20 to 30 million in our case all we need
to do is sample 2 million because
remember we are enriching and the third
point is that 2 million reads we have
about five times more sensitivity if you
were to take that same sample and do 30
million reads for whole meta-genome
which means is that in order to be equal
and in the amount of sensitivity that
the assay has given you you would need
to sequence 5 times 30 will be about
something about 150 million reads which
is exactly which is very close to our
estimates also especially when we are
doing the environmental samples just
like in the case of bird flu because a
mod a scoop of soil has about 10 to the
power of 6 bacteria in it so because it
is so dense you mean so much
so much sampling and the graph on the
right what it tells you is that
regardless when we sequence a sample on
the platform we can instantly put that
sample in amount of is quantity and
title expression into low medium and
high so without looking at anything else
the asset instantly can quantify an
infection into these categories and yes
it can provide you your IU ml and
everything all of that but it can also
give you a complete overview that based
on all the samples have been tested
where does this sample stack up in terms
of its quantity that is present
moving on here is an example from the
skin infections and then pension - skin
infections are very hard so in this
instance the assay from the PATA genome
to the skin infection portion of it is
designed to identify all 63 pathogenic
species wherever they are available and
on the right hand side it shows you an
example of a standard serial dilution
and we're showing m-marry Miam where
what it shows you that the assay can go
down and detect as little as about two
CF years and and also where your 16s
specific or even a genetic a specific
PCR will start to fail the assay keeps
on working in summary
platform in the assest so far because we
also sequencing very less amount it it
is actually about 10 to 30 times cheaper
to use than whole matter genome
sequencing from your sequencing
perspective it has the ability to give
you 3 to 9 times faster results it
already provides you about 5 times 250
times the clinical sensitivity of a
whole meta-genome assay and what it
means is that and we already saw that in
the space of the PCR it it there is as
sensitive at 2 million reads as a nested
PCR and it provides you about a hundred
x SC a few more than 100 x CFU detection
when compared with generics 16 as pcr
about so this is the only site about the
product we want to launch it in about 29
19 as an ru o LD t it will be priced at
$300 and will have a turnaround time of
24 hours and somewhere down the road
will also because the reason it has to
be audio because as I mentioned you can
you know you you can certainly try but
having an FDA approved assay for 1,400
is not I don't know how long it will
take
so it will also have and the FDA C
eHealth cannot approve version or
specific syndromic conditions
I accept says GI and all of that and
that will have a turnaround time
depending upon the syndrome anywhere
from 12 to 24 hours that will be priced
between 300 to 1500 and sometime down
the road we are also planning to
introduce a single agent cartridge based
a slide
applications of the platform I hope I
have convinced you that using a genomic
target capture approach we can handle
the problem of undiagnosed infections it
can be used in epidemiological
investigations transmission and tracking
of hospital-acquired infections
antibiotic resistance surveillance in
hospitals and environmental monitoring
so what does that lead us if you go back
to that to that iceberg yeah we as I
mentioned that we believe that the only
way of addressing the problem is
addressing the entire iceberg and we
believe that time has arrived to address
the iceberg and we're trying to actively
address the iceberg and we'll be very
happy to hear from you your questions
your concerns or anything around it in
any way we can help with that thank you
very much I really once again want to
thank the organizers as well all of you
who have Spaniard who are here listening
to this event I hope it has a big burst
your time thank you very much thank you
dr. Kinnear for that informative
presentation we will now start the Q&A
portion of the webinar and we'll address
some of the most commonly asked
questions by our viewers if you have any
questions you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen and click the send button
our speaker will follow up with your
questions via email let's get started
our first question is how can this
technology be employed at a hospital oh
that's an excellent question
I mean you can employ it at various you
can
as you can actually take a staging
approach for example you can employ it
for a single indication where you think
that is the most important aspect in
your Institute and we have many
instances of Thyer so for example we are
working with a major hospital who had
really the problem with PGI infections
so yes you can you can bring in the
technology as a GI infection but then
where it really helps and shines and
becomes very cost effective is that if
you if you convert your molecular
testing and even your routine testing
especially culture onto a genomic
platform like this what it means is now
all of a sudden you don't have to
maintain all those incubators all those
cultures all those hundreds of PCR
primers you can have a single as saying
which you can then batch at the end of
the day and run all your samples on a
single assay but it also does to you
that it actually bring your sequencing
cost down and your asset cost for
example we have done these analysis
where if you were to do say only 96
patients every all samples every time
your sequencing costs will reduce to
about $30 so yes - and yeah I hope I've
answered it is that yes you can
introduce the technology as to address a
specific problem or to adopt it as a
platform and the other advantages of
adopting has a platform also that it
also allows you to remove so much excess
things that have to be maintained and
cultures and things like that
thank you does the assay need any
specialized equipment good yeah okay but
yes they can be at the moment can be
are you or an LD P in any in any
molecular diagnostic laboratory and all
they need is medium sized DNA DNA
sequencer the technology is compatible
with all the DNA sequences because if
you think about it all you're doing is
taking that DNA enriching it and putting
it onto the cyst onto the sequencer
we're not doing anything to the sample
that's also an important feature the
integrity of the sample and its relative
ratios and expressions nothing changes
you just enrich it and put it on to move
the sequencer so sorry has to answer you
would require next-generation sequencing
instrument thank you and we have time
for one more question
how will the assay be reimbursed as an
excellent question so in the
hospitalized setting piace is it can be
easily reimbursed under the DRG pathway
which is the diagnostic related group
when the answer is actually introduced
as an FDA approval Health Canada
approved version for these syndromes it
will follow the current CPT course or
those syndromes if they exist or will
file any ones if they need to be thank
you I would like to once again thank dr.
Kadir for his presentation would also
like to thank lab routes for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through December
13th 2018 you'll receive an email from
lab roots letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
event that's all for now thank you for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
goodbye